inflation in the united states of
america is absolutely insane right now
look at the numbers 6.2 cpi the american
people haven't seen a number like that
in over 30 years was the government
responding with printing trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars they
have printed almost 40 percent of the
money supply in the last 18 months that
is insane that is not how you handle
inflation that is just making it worse
and you know who's suffering the average
person the inequality rates in this
country have gone through the roof
the government is not doing anything to
help this out gas is up around 60 in the
last year stake up 20 percent literally
you go to chipotle more more more more
more money they want 10 15 20 a bull
it's absolutely crazy you can't do
anything to stop it
i have chosen bitcoin to defend my
inflation and be a hedge against
inflation bitcoin has appreciated over 2
million in the last decade at a 200
annual rate it's insane it's one of the
best inflation heads that we've ever
seen it's the hardest money
sound money it's what you need it's what
everyone needs it's a perfect store
value for you as an individual while
you're at it go get some merchandise
some bitcoin merchandise at
thebestbusinessshow.com got everything
from money printer t-shirts with your
own pals to pay me bitcoin t-shirts
hoodies everything you need trillionaire
energy it's all there go check it out at
thebestbusinessshow.com